[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
chad dabo pleads not guilty to murder
charges as lori valodebo
is ordered committed to a mental health
facility our legal analysis on the
latest twists and turns in the doomsday
cult couple saga
a murder defendant breaks down while
admitting to killing his five-year-old
son
but with his confession now recanted
what will the jury believe
hey he is he doesn't happen
plus did a murder victim admit to being
an alibi for a real estate heir accused
in his wife's disappearance
the shocking testimony in the trial of
robert durst and her stepping in
making a phone call and leaving it as a
suspense
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the husband and the so-called doomsday
couple is pleading not guilty to murder
charges
as a judge ordered his wife to be
committed due to mental health concerns
charges mr dabel the offenses of
conspiracy to commit first-degree murder
and grand theft by deception chad dabo
appeared in fremont county idaho court
for his arraignment
daebel is accused of murdering his
former wife tammy debell
as well as the two children of his
current wife lori valo mr daybel in this
case then you were brought before this
court to answer for the indictment filed
in this case which is
which alleges you've committed serious
crimes in that
eight felony charges have been filed on
the grand jury's indictment
the bodies of seven-year-old joshua j.j
valo and sixteen-year-old tylie ryan
were discovered
one year ago buried in chad's property
dabo faces up to the death penalty
but prosecutors have not yet said if
they'll seek the highest sentence if
convicted
very well not guilty pleas are entered
as to all the counts in the indictment
lori also faces charges of murder and
fraud but a judge has now ordered her
committed to a mental health facility
for up to 90 days
prosecutors are no longer contesting a
psychological assessment
deeming laurie incompetent to stand
trial and defense attorneys for lawyer
are asking the court to show
why one of lori's friends should not be
held in contempt for failing to comply
with their subpoena
she secretly recorded phone calls with
lori which have been handed over as
evidence
if you really love me you wouldn't have
told the police that i had jj with me
that's not that's not what a friend does
i do and i did exactly what i felt the
lord was instructed me to do
joining us today is new york law school
professor kirk burkhalter and terry
austin
kirk up until now chad and lori daybell
were going to be trying together
chad was a reign alone could this be the
beginning of this
this trial being split in two
oh it certainly could so laurie uh
seems that she will be unfit to stand
trial and that won't occur anytime soon
so
prosecution the question is how long
would they wish to delay
the trial of tad you have these heinous
crimes children involved
and certainly the prosecution absolutely
would like to move forward
this may present some problem for the
prosecution when you have two people
acting in concert as such
however i suspect we'll see this case
move forward with just chad
i can see that as well terry does the
prosecution not
challenging lori valo dabel's competency
tell us anything
and what happens next for her you know
what brian i was actually shocked that
the prosecution
didn't you know object to this this is a
huge issue and it really could delay the
trial but maybe wood thought it would be
futile to object to it even the
indictment itself
said that chad and lori were endorsing
these religious beliefs that they
believed that tammy was possessed by
spirits and so maybe would recognize the
fact that
objecting to it wasn't going to change
anything and it means that she is going
to be
put into the care of the department of
health and welfare
and she's going to undergo treatment
until she's
restored to her mental competency and if
that doesn't happen they'll just
keep getting extensions until in fact
she is found to be competent
to actually stand trial whenever that
might be yeah
and as we understand with that it's
going to be like a 90-day process so
they have 90 days maybe they extend it
more
and it can be extended almost
indefinitely depending on her competency
but of course we've got you covered and
we'll let you know how that plays out
now to california where two people
accused in the death
and cover-up of a six-year-old boy will
remain in jail for now
law and crimes anjanet levy is here with
the latest on the murder of aidan laos
angenette brian marcus
aries and winley made their first court
appearances
aries is charged with shooting and
killing aiden leos and winley
is accused of helping cover up the crime
despite objections from their attorneys
the judge allowed cameras to record the
arraignment for marcus aries and win lee
prosecutors argued for a high bail i'm
asking for that
for three reasons the first being the
seriousness of the crime
the second being he's a danger to the
public
and the third is his flight risk the
orange county district attorney says
aries fired his gun from the white
volkswagen lee was
driving on a freeway back on may 21st
aiden was shot sitting in his booster
seat
a manhunt followed for the vehicle
involved and the people inside
as a mom i just my heart
was breaking the moment that we found
out about this heinous crime
tips and donations for a reward poured
in
we all related to this situation of just
driving our
little boy to school and suddenly he's
dead
crying mommy my tummy hurts
aiden's mother held her son as he died
and remembered him at a memorial service
to my aiden
i love watching you sleep in the morning
as you're the most beautiful boy i've
ever seen
as the court case moves forward a judge
ordered marcus ariza's bail set at two
million dollars
when lee's is five hundred thousand
dollars just looking at the charging
document mr eric
is the danger and the potential greater
risk
to the community
now both aries and lee will be back in
court next week for the remainder of
their arraignments at that time
the judge said he could either raise the
bail amounts
or lower them the judge actually set the
bail higher than allowed by the
guidelines are called for by the
guidelines
at the request of the prosecutor brian
now andrea
is this it for arrest in this case
you know that is something that the d.a
addressed uh when he held a press
conference he said that there's a lot of
chatter on social media
people calling for more arrests in this
case speculating and saying that
other people had to have helped cover
for these two but he said right now they
have no
evidence that anyone else but aries and
lee
were involved in this case and they've
asked that people
leave the family members alone because
they do not believe they were involved
yeah i would guess that this case is
still ongoing as they're trying to see
any leads or people who may be connected
with this but so far do the charges make
sense as to how they're being applied in
this case angenette
yeah i would say so so far you know the
d.a said that they initially charged
winley with
murder uh then they backed off of that
when they filed the formal charges with
the
court they filed they charged her as an
accessory after the fact so they
certainly said they don't have the
evidence right now to charge her with
murder
a reason they feel they can prove and
they called it a rock solid case
all right we'll see how that plays out
thank you angelette still ahead on lawn
crime daily did a wisconsin woman murder
her friend with eye drops to steal
hundreds of thousands of dollars
but first confession of course a closer
look at joseph daniel's interrogation
and the agent who interviewed him you
decide next
[Music]
welcome back a tennessee man broke down
while admitting to killing his
five-year-old
autistic son now on trial he's recanting
that confession
but prosecutors say he gave it of his
own free will
what made you stop when i realized i
lost control
two days after joseph clyde daniels was
reported as missing his father joseph
ray daniels spoke to investigators at
the police station
about when he claims to have last seen
his son i got up that morning
i got his clothes i went there and he
was gone
he wasn't in the bed nearly two and a
half hours of the four hour interview
was played for the jury
was it an accident no
no was it an accident i did not feel
that you intentionally did it
daniel's told many variations of what
happened to baby joe with one
consistency
it all started when baby joe peed on the
floor
i saw baby joe he was laughing
he had peter before
i was not happy about that i love my boy
so much that
i won't do anything really you don't
because you know where he's at you're
not having
out of the way in a weird way i don't
know why
[Music]
finally daniels confessed to hitting the
boy over and over
was he crying
yeah how long do you think that lasted
for
five ten minutes he kept screaming
daniel said he placed the boy's
unresponsive body in a field
crossing his arms across his chest he
attempted to bring police to baby joe's
body but the five-year-old's remains
still have not been found on
cross-examination agent joey boyd of the
tennessee bureau of investigation
asked about inconsistencies in daniel's
confession with
the evidence he said that he struck him
in the head
in the back and also in the face is that
correct
next question is and would it surprise
you not to find some blood
in that area my answer it would not
surprise me
given the age of joe clyde his stature
so you don't believe joseph daniels beat
joe clyde daniels to the point that he
bled
i can't prove that
so he could very well be in line to try
to satisfy
what you wanted no sir i don't believe
that's the case
daniel's wife crystal daniels is also
facing charges and is set to stand trial
at a later date
agent boyd says both parents are to
blame for baby joe's death
and both of those choices would make him
a murderer yes or no
uh yes sir i would describe them both
that way
back with us is new york law school
professor kirk burkhalter and terry
austin
terry prosecutors know what the defense
is going to argue so what about this
confession is going to make it stick
you know brian in my opinion the
confession is definitely going to
stick because it was not coerced first
of all
we know that daniels came to the police
station on his own accord
to confess the confession was
not that long i mean it was four hours
we seen longer confessions we saw
in the christian bahana rivera case it
was 11 hours and that one
stood ground so in fact that was a
conviction and you know we also saw here
that
the interrogators they were actually
saying that they had information but
they did not put words in his mouth so i
definitely think
that the confection the confession is
definitely going to stand up i don't
think that it is going to be found to be
coerced or be a false
uh confession all right kirk positive
confrontation
move towards uh acknowledgement repeat
admissions of guilt
this is textbook read technique in this
interrogation
can the defense argue this is a part of
their false confession
well certainly the defense will attempt
to argue the problem is the supreme
court
has upheld all types of interrogation
techniques uh interview techniques
uh police can lie they can present uh
information evidence that they don't
have
as terry just mentioned we've seen
interrogations and interviews
far longer than this so this is the kind
of
pseudo good cop good cop bad cop type
confession i think the the defense will
argue it
however um they're not going to win that
argument this is done
over and over and it was not coercive
was not coercive at all it was voluntary
and that's the key yeah we're definitely
i think at least i think we're all on
the same page
we're definitely going to probably see a
case put on by the defense if they're
gonna make this argument there's gonna
be someone making the arguments to
exactly we're gonna talk about it's
gonna be really interesting
to see how that plays out thank you both
coming up on law on crime daily
r kelly puts the keys in his ignition
and is breaking up with his attorneys
plus a story of espionage political
corruption and mob directed
assassination attempts
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross reports on the division of light
and power next
we're back a woman in wisconsin is now
under arrest for allegedly murdering her
friend
with eye drops
jesse krashewski called police saying
her friend 60 year old lynn hernan
was dead in october 2018. hernan's death
was initially ruled as a drug overdose
prescription pills and crushed medicine
were found around her body
police now say hernan's death was a
homicide according to a police report
krashewski posed as the victim's friend
taking over 300 thousand dollars from
her
then spiking hernan's water bottle with
a lethal level of eye drops
the 37 year old is charged with
intentional homicide and felony theft
also in wisconsin a former pharmacist
will spend three years in prison
for sabotaging vials of the modern coven
19 vaccine stephen brandenburg admitted
to spoiling 500 doses of the vaccine at
a hospital in grafton
brandenburg pled guilty to two counts of
tampering with evidence for leaving the
vials outside
last december prosecutors say he
believed in conspiracy theories
and intentionally tried to ruin the
vaccines because he didn't believe they
were safe
57 people received doses of the vaccines
from the vials before brandenburg was
discovered
rmb singer r kelly is trying to fire his
criminal defense attorney
stephen greenberg r kelly appeared in
court in new york on wednesday
two months before the anticipated start
of his trial for racketeering charges
the judge asked kelly if he wished to
dump greenberg and co-counsel
the singer replied quote absolutely yes
ma'am your honor
kelly is currently in jail in chicago
awaiting two separate trials
there for accusations of filming himself
having sex with underage girls
greenberg has previously appeared on the
law and crime network defending kelly
uh obviously the law of averages is
going to catch up with us at some point
but you know it's it's this sort of
buyer's remorse
in many of these cases with many of
these allegations
these were people that were ecstatic to
be with our kelly they were happy to be
with our kelly
and now someone else has said to them oh
no it was no good
times have changed and and in hindsight
they're sort of repurposing the
encounters
a new book is out this week digging into
the mafia's influence in ohio during the
1970s
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross has more
thanks brian coming up this week on
brian ross investigates
the never before told tale of corruption
powerful interests and mafia hits told
by a man who was at the time
the youngest mayor of a major american
city ever
dennis kucinich of cleveland who i
covered when i was a young reporter
i was really lucky to get out of there
alive uh during that time
uh you talk about shots fired into your
home right there
in that house yeah right uh right behind
me uh on the one on the left there was i
powered wiper
shot that that went through the place
where i was sitting
and had i not moved a split second
earlier would have uh
it would have hit me that's coming up
this week i'm brian ross investigates on
the law and crime
trial network back to you brian
thanks brian when we come back did susan
berman admit to covering for robert
durst in the disappearance of his first
wife
her alleged statement to a teen before
she was shot and killed
next
welcome back one of the witnesses in the
murder trial of robert durst now says
the victim once claimed to be the alibi
for the real estate error accused in his
wife's disappearance
susan berman was shot to death in her
home in december 2000.
prosecutors say her best friend robert
durst killed her because she threatened
to go
public with what she knew about durst's
involvement with his wife's missing
since 1982 the daughter of berman's
former boyfriend says she met berman
when she was in the sixth grade
and they became incredibly close she
then described the conversation she had
with berman when she was in the eighth
grade
she was you know it's just another
interesting story
she was telling me and she was telling
me about
her friend and how his wife had
disappeared and how she had been an
alibi or made a phone call for him so
that it wasn't suspicious
and um she left it kind of like a
cliffhanger
you know i was she left me in suspense
like did he do it and she kind of
smirked and
said i don't know you know what do you
think kind of thing who is she talking
about
bobby durst and his um
wife kathleen okay well did she use the
word kathleen or did she just say his
wife
uh i i can't really remember at this
point
how certain are you that susan berman
told you that she helped her friend
bobby
with this situation by providing some
sort of an alibi
completely is there any doubt in your
mind no
on cross the defense asked her if she
previously described her memory
of this conversation as foggy
i don't remember saying that but i'm
sure it's true okay
so you're 13 years old or 14 at one time
you said this happened when you were 13
just now in court you said it happened
when you were 14
but it's fair to say when you
think about it all the facts as to what
happened
are as you described it previously foggy
not clear not detailed not all
not all but at least some correct some
yes
kirk fading memories is going to be at
the heart of the defense's argument
how did this witness come across to you
i think she was quite credible you know
you can remember that you wore that
particular tie
or that suit but you just don't remember
what day or what restaurant was it at
this restaurant or the other restaurant
but certainly you remember you wore that
tie
because you got soup on it and she comes
across credible she remembers this event
doesn't remember exactly how old she was
13 14
she's better than me 13 17 who knows
right so
but i do think that she was quite
credible and it's always good when
witnesses
admit that their memory was foggy
instead of trying to cover it up
i think that adds to the credibility
here now terry to kirk's point the
witness seemed pretty sure of a few
things
how do you think the jury will read this
witness i think the witness like kirk
said
is going to be believed by the jury and
remember brian she's not the only
witness who said
that susan berman told her that she did
a favor for durst and by the way this is
all hearsay on top of hearsay
judge windham apparently just allows
everybody to say anything they want to
say but the other witness is miriam
barnes and she's a friend and she
said that susan berman told her the same
thing about a phone call and so
this is an important piece for the
prosecution they're trying to show
that there was some motive for durst to
kill berman
and the motive was that berman knew
about
kathy durst and that apparently durst
killed
kathy and so it's very important for
them to establish
that susan berman was really
talking about this phone call that she
made to different people so i think it's
an important part of the prosecution's
case and i think that mellie kaufman
and frankly miriam barnes both came
across as
very credible witnesses terry you
mentioned the hearsay issue do you think
it rises to the level of potentially
being an appellate issue
that could have this case overturned if
durst lives that long
yes absolutely i think there are so many
instances in this case where
that could be a grounds for appeal all
right thank you both for joining us and
thank you for joining us here on law and
crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you